So we are lucky enough to be here this morning to interview Charlie White, and it's May 18,
2011.
It's too late.
Thank you so much for agreeing to do this.
I want to start off by just asking you to tell us your earliest recollections, where
you're born, what year, and where you grew up.
I was born in Detroit, Michigan, in April, 2014.
I was the youngest of nine children, four brothers and four sisters all over the place.
Their two of us left myself and brother next to me.
Typical shout, we were poor, but Norm said, that's not good enough because I never starved
to eat.
I always had food.
I always had a roof over my head when I close and the whole thing.
And the old saying was, cardboard and shoe, we had a few, sure, sure.
But I was just a typical childhood in those days.
What kind of things do you remember doing as a child, playing games, playing sports, my brother
next to me.
I thought, kind of following his footsteps.
He played basketball, and he played in high school.
He didn't go to college, but he played high school, but I used to watch his games, and
we'd hit the playgrounds on the weekends, we'd Saturday morning, had to break a dog.
We were out in the alleys, and on the playgrounds playing basketball.
It was more like a religion, I mean, we played all kind of sports, you know, and contrary to
property of relief.
There was a pretty good hockey player in my neighborhood, you know, being wintertime, we played
hockey, and we played tennis and all that, but the basketball just became the sport, basketball
and football.
It's a good baseball player, it's true.
The basketball became the game of a choice, and I played YMCA, a Jewish community center.
Well, also one thing I did when I was 10 years old, 19 years old, I used to swim for
the YMCA, and I wasn't too bad, but we transferred closer to a place near my home, and everybody
left the YMCA.
The coach left and everybody followed him, and we used to swim against the girls town teams
from the country clubs and all that, and we did pretty good against these guys, oh yeah.
So swimming was big to me for about three, four years, from about nine to about 13.
I'm still playing basketball, but I did, they're in the summer, I just swimming, and
they're even at big clubs.
Sure, sure.
But that's basically what we do.
What do you recall growing up in Detroit around the racialization of Detroit was there.
You said you were trying to get the kids in the country club to be there, sort of having
a kind of feeling towards you guys?
Well, they did, but I mean nothing was said, I mean, you know, they just felt, you know,
they had that superior feeling that, you know, they were better, because they had much better
facilities.
We had decent facilities, but they had the country clubs and the whole thing, and, but,
you know, that feeling was there, and it was always there that we wanted to win.
Detroit was a, I love Detroit, but it was polarized.
I mean, most of the blacks lived in about three or four different areas, and they were
there too, and Jewish people lived there, and the Polish people lived on a little place
called Amdrami.
Sure.
And great athletes came up, Amdrami, and that was like dindy high schools in Amdrami,
so we played against each other in this throughout the city, but it was mostly, there was
only one that I can remember, one school at that time that had mixed athletic teams, and
nothing.
Yeah.
Okay.
Which was one of the top schools in the city.
Roughly what year were we talking?
I'm talking about in the mid-50s.
Mid-50s, yeah.
Right.
So your high school, as I'm here, used to say, was not desegregated?
No.
Well, I went to cash tech.
Yeah, sorry.
To begin with, but I didn't stay there, I ended up back in my neighbor's school, but yeah,
the neighbor's school that I played the most basketball and was not desegregated.
The cash tech was, and they had, obviously, pretty good teams.
Okay.
But, you know, pretty much it, I did a lot of hard jobs growing up as a kid to generate
income.
You know, I learned this from all my brothers and sisters who all worked and went to school
and did all the things.
They all graduated from high school, and none with the college, I was the only one who
worked.
Okay.
But I worked for, you know, cutting lawns, washing windows, you know, whatever.
Sure.
And I got a job with large grocery chain, Kroger's, and I started working in the meat
department, just kind of cleaning up and everything, and then I ended up getting a permanent job
as a stockboy, and, you know, doing okay.
And the church was just, it was rough in the neighborhood.
I mean, you had to kind of establish yourself, but sure.
I decided in 1958 that I'd see it enough, and the friend of mine and I decided to say
let's go see the world and join the military.
And we could have gone in for two years and gone to the Far East, but I said, now let's
go in for three and go to Europe.
I'm sorry, we're going to see a few more places, and that's what happened.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
And you were about 18.
17, 18.
20.
Almost 20.
19.
And I played a lot of basketball there, was there?
In the military.
Yeah.
He talked a little bit about that.
Of course.
Well, we came in, and I went in to Fort Knox, a little bit right outside, a little bit.
And they had a camp team, and I went out for it, but I didn't want to, in order to make
that team, you had to kind of stay in the States, and you travel around, and I said,
I don't want to stay here, so I want to go to Europe.
I want to go to Europe.
And I got on the team there, and we played, we could be at like 50 games schedules and then
we had to turn them, and so yeah.
At the series?
Yeah.
Lee?
And then I played a lot of games, enjoyed myself, you know, we went to, went all over Berlin,
all over Germany.
Right.
And at that time, the military was disagreeing, I remember.
Oh, yeah.
So you were actually working with white teammates.
But there was several racial issues in the military.
Can you talk about them?
Well, the majority MPs were, military police were white and from the South.
Okay.
And they harassed us consistently, whenever we would be out.
There was one African guy there named Bobby, something other, and he had a,
a club, a very nice popular club, and we would go down there and, you know, once, twice
a month, MPs would come and just kind of raid the club, you know, pull everybody out
of school, hang, coffee, you know, and we, our team used to go down there, but this was
a track team at this time.
Okay.
And we had white kids on the track team, and they would tell them to go home, but they
wouldn't go.
They would stay with us, and they would take us, you know, to jail, to lock up.
But we'd get out the next couple of hours because we'd call our colonel and blah, blah,
blah, blah.
You know, it was just arrest.
Sure.
And it just, it just continued.
Yeah, sure.
It continued.
What else was some of your experiences in Germany as, so I meant, what position did you
have in the military then?
Because it wasn't just fully accurate, right?
You had a regular job.
Yeah.
I was just, I was in the armored infantry, what they called it, but I didn't spend a lot
of time.
I spent what they called TDY, which is temporary duty.
Now with the play sports, but I also was on the track team.
Oh, I didn't even know they had to.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now I jumped.
And triple jumped and brought jumped, the mouse long jumped, whatever.
But yeah, I did that too.
So I did that to pretty much keep from, you know, doing them on the, every day, duty
is current duty.
Yeah, right, right.
Kids in patrol, you know, little sorts of things.
Right.
Yeah.
So did someone recognize you in the military as being a potential athlete for eventually
college or how did that team talk to you now about how that was really funny.
We were in the gym one day and I was shooting around.
And this kid from Southern California, he's on our team, Jones, Dick Jones.
He came in the gym and he asked me, see, what are you going to do?
I was getting close to my time to come back three states and he said, what are you going
to do when you get out of the military?
I said, you know, I really didn't talk much about it.
And he said, you got to go out to California and go to junior college and say junior college
is free.
Maybe you can get a scholarship to a four-year school.
And I thought he was joking, so I threw the ball out and told him to get out of here, you
know, chase him out of the gym.
Well, guess what happened?
Uh-huh.
Just that.
I did just that.
I got sipped to California from Germany, got out of the army, went to junior college, then
came with Durgan State.
Okay.
Now, the thing that I noticed when I got here, I started seeing names in the paper from
some of the other junior colleges in Southern California, guys I knew from Detroit.
So there was a lot of young kids kept from each other who came out to California and went
to junior college.
What was that?
What do you think?
Because we heard some very similar thing from, no, because he said that a lot of guys from
his neighborhood is Washington ended up in California.
What was maybe going on back then?
Well, for one thing, the junior colleges back there were not free.
Worked free in East Coast?
East Coast.
They were free out here.
Okay.
If you were 21, you could establish residency and you didn't have to pay out of state fees.
So you could go to junior college free.
And these coaches would help you get a little odds out here in there where you could work.
And then you got a scholarship to a four-year school.
So a lot of kids and plus, you know, who wouldn't want to come to California out of Detroit?
You know what I mean?
It's snowed this high and freezing and there's a lot of different things going on.
Plus we're getting in trouble, friends, relatives, you know, we're in that mix, you know, that
you see every day, I mean, when I was about 17, you had to be 18 to go into the pool halls
but everybody forwards some kind of paper.
And I used to hang around in the pool hall and, you know, see a lot of stuff going on.
So you want to get away from that, mainly, just, you know, just, more future.
Yeah, yeah, just get out of that mix for a while.
And that was, you know, they just got started coming once a couple of guys came.
Yeah.
A lot of guys started coming.
And like I said, I saw the guys' names down in L.A. and different places from Detroit.
And so I said, yeah, it was the best thing for me to do.
But anyway, that's what I did.
I came to Oregon state and, you know, I'm going to come back down to that mix.
So you're playing in a junior college and someone identifies you and says, who was that?
You know, Paul and I were talking about that.
Well, I don't recall who it was, but I think it was a guy that played with Paul, his name
was Doug.
And I don't remember his last name, I'm not a fact of last time.
I think I heard he was in pretty poor health, but he and Paul played together and they
were good friends.
Sure.
And I think he might have seen me play in some tournament.
He lived in the general area.
Okay.
And Paul and told him about me.
But one thing that happened, the year before it came, where that skill came down to recruit
me.
In my fact, it came to my house, and I talked with him, you know, and I didn't feel
good, just didn't feel, feel warm and fuzzy, I guess.
And then a couple other coaches told me some stories about him, you know, that I probably
wouldn't get to play much and, you know, sitting on the bench and that sort of thing.
And I said, well, that's just, it's not a good sign, so I just didn't come here.
And then the next year when Paul came down and we sat down and talked, like I said, I
just felt it.
You know, you feel something.
And like I said, when we talked about me graduating, I told him I need probably more
than two years.
He said, well, I can't give you that in writing, but I promise you.
Yeah.
I'll give you two years.
That you graduate.
Yeah.
Not anything over the two that I needed to graduate that I would graduate.
And I felt that.
And then when I came up here, they focused on education right away as opposed to, you
know, just ask about it and laid out what I needed to do, and that's when I started taking
classes and got through.
Yeah.
Come back, though, to your situation with FlatSkill.
At that point, the team was completely not to say, the team was sacred in the sense that
there was no African-Americans on the team at that point.
But instead of the California, there were actually work teams that were very, well, sure, very
mixed.
Sure.
I wonder how, in your opinion, how did you think that he sort of rationalized that he wasn't
going to allow his team necessarily to have an edge?
Because at that point, I think it was really recognized that having African-American players
on your team was really an edge because they run a different game to the game that Norm
was actually talking to us about the game, that he was forced to play.
And that is a very kind of contri-
Sure.
Control.
It was that completely different.
Running plays.
Yeah.
Picking screens.
We're on a playground.
It was, you know.
You just got it done?
Yeah, behind the back.
Yeah.
Through the legs or whatever.
You know, we were out of here, whooping there before it came in the college.
Sure.
You throw the ball up.
You know, I really don't know.
Yeah, I try to figure this out because every year, and so that's had some good teams.
Yeah, he went to the battle for it.
But every year, almost every year, but for two years, specifically, that just spoke his
heart, I know.
Okay.
Be a Russell.
Yeah.
Was at the USF.
Okay.
And they always played in the region, it was on the West Coast.
And the West Coast teams used to beat him every time, and all of them always had players
of color.
Right.
And I would have thought to myself, you know.
You know, I don't know, you know, and you know, the thing that they mentioned about the
quota thing they had, you know, you start one at home, two on the road, but be a Russell
calling the phrase, you say, but five when you're behind.
Yeah.
Be a Russell started that now, but I heard another explanation of that.
You start one at home, and two on the road, because you got to have somebody to roam
together.
Oh, interesting.
You see that.
This is what I was told, you know, you wouldn't, you know, at that time.
Yeah, sure.
And also at that time, in some parts of the country, you couldn't find logic for black players.
So, you know, if you had to go play in some areas, you know, this is kind of like the old
Kentucky Robinson, Glenn baseball, the team stayed here, and he found him a place to stay
in the neighborhood at someone's home, you know, like that.
So I know some coaches had mentioned that, and they were aware of that, and some thought
of, you know, uncomfortable with that.
But I don't, I just don't know, I think he might have wanted to pull the trigger, but I
don't know.
He just did.
Yeah.
And plus, there weren't a lot of kids up here for him to recruit, and most of his kids were
local, though, and if he'd go back and look.
Yeah.
Now, I think at that time Washington probably had some.
Washington had an African-American players, yeah.
Yeah.
I was wondering when I was doing the research to see what was, you know, you saw that California
clearly had lost, and you saw, you see Adel had a, you know, the rest of Oregon, they
played them all the time, and yeah, this guy was kind of holding the line, and I was
comparing to Rupp when I was kind of understanding what was going on, what was this guy trying
to do?
But that was the feeling pretty much amongst those, you know, athletes in California and
in different places that he didn't really want in the African-American players, really.
Right.
So, and I guess nobody wanted to be the first with him, because there was not that good
feeling about, you know, being quite a pair, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so when Paul the Lenta came down, did he ever tell you that, hey, I'm going to be the
coach next, because I know I'm in line, I'm in line, yeah, no, he was actually the coach
when he came down.
Oh, he's actually, you know, already got in the job?
He already got in the job.
Oh, I see, okay, right.
I had read about it in the paper, but I didn't think much of it really didn't, he called
me, contacted me.
Sure.
And then he came to talk to me.
Right, right, right.
Okay.
So let's not care the story on, just talk about you now arriving on campus, and what were
some of your earliest recollections for you, arriving on campus, you're seeing the plays,
what was that like?
One thing that was really funny, there was a female in the Charlie White.
Name Charlie White?
Yes.
Okay, all right.
Well, I got to meet her later, look, I'm at her at a party, really, yes, but anyway,
when I first got here, they had us doing jobs in cottage growth, logging, logging.
Okay.
So in the office?
Yeah.
That's beginning of summer, so I went right into work.
Now, cottage growth is down toward Eugene, I think is east of Eugene, out in the wilderness.
So they took me down there, and I mean, this was not a good situation.
The first day I was there, took me in the evening, and I said, hey, being me in at night.
So the next morning I get up and I come down and everybody's staring, and then the next
day, someone told me that it would be good if I didn't come out at night.
So I called Paul and said, I'm leaving now, so they sent somebody and got me, and I moved
in Eugene.
There was some guys in Eugene, there was three or four guys in this apartment, and it was
makes a couple of white students and a couple of, and they were athletes, and they brought
me down there, and I, and every morning, what we would do, we would catch a bus from
Eugene to the cottage growth, and we would come back to Eugene.
So they kept the job, but I didn't live in cottage growth, because I told them I wasn't
staying.
They need to get me out of here now.
So I came to Eugene, and then I worked that summer in the woods, which was good.
We made a lot of money.
I've been paying a whole lot, but at that time, it was a lot of money.
And we didn't have a place to spend it, so all summer long, we worked, stuck chicken
in the bank, so the school started, we had a little money.
Right.
It was common for us.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, we could work.
First, we got a stipend.
Okay.
Yeah, a monthly stipend.
So then, start the season, and like I said, we had a, we didn't have a very good team.
We were seven, seven in the back.
But actually, it wasn't the pack eight.
Everybody says the pack eight.
It was the AAWU, which is the athletic association of Western universities.
Okay.
But it was the original eight schools, the two in the Oregon, two in Washington, two in
Southern Canada, two in Northern Canada.
It was the pack eight, you know, the name pack eight became on the later, but anyway,
we were seven, seven in confidence.
I think we were 14, 10 overall or something like that.
And, you know, we, you know, we weren't really thinking anything big the next year.
We just wanted to be competitive, and I had played a small floor with my first year here.
But then they put me in guard the next year, and, you know, and all the guys, the only
new guy that came in really was, that really helped us with Harry, the only new guy, Harry
Gunna.
Okay.
Yeah.
So they came in, and, you know, we, we, we, we, we were like a good seven, eight, and deep,
you know.
What year was that?
They came in, because we didn't find them.
65.
But Laura was not African-American.
We married Harry Gunna was.
Harry Gunna was.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
We'll tell you that part of the research.
Yeah.
Okay.
So tell me about that, that reception that you receive, you feel that you receive from
a student body in that first year, and then in the next year that you feel.
Well, like I said, you know, I'm oblivious to a lot, and I've been a lot of places, and,
you know, and all.
Yeah.
And so, I mean, sure, you got some looks, and, you know, you know, I just kept going, you
know.
I was here to do what I was here to do.
One incident was, one of the freshmen players, who I knew, you know, not very well, but
I, you know, I knew who he was.
We were on campus, and he was with his girlfriend, and he stopped.
And he introduced me, and you see me at a comment, oh, you're the one in my girlfriend's
class.
Yes.
Okay.
And I said the one what?
And she was totally embarrassed, and couldn't even answer, so I just said, I'll see you guys
later.
Right.
But, you know, that was kind of funny, but, you know, you know, but, like I said, most
of the kids up here had never been around any, any back people, let alone go to school
with them, or, you know, because I had run into that in the army.
I mean, guys in the army, he lived, mostly southerners, who had seen, they told me they'd
seen back people from a distance, but, you know, they didn't know, you know, and that was
that.
Yeah, and they're from the south, living in a little small town, Mississippi, and places like
Right.
But I didn't feel anything in classes, plus in street tunes.
Yeah, the professors, I didn't feel anything in teachers or students in the classes, you know,
there was an occasional, yeah, a lot of somebody's car, you know.
Okay.
Yeah.
And in finding accommodation in Corvallis and recreation in Corvallis, what was that like
for you?
Well, the one, the main thing is when I, the house I moved into when I came down, it was
already active at the African Americans, so I don't have a problem with that.
And how did you find that?
To the coach find that for you?
That, that accommodation.
I think so.
Okay.
Yeah.
I think so.
But they were football players.
Football players.
And one was a non-athlete.
Okay.
He's a pharmacist.
But when we were in a group, we always told everybody he played tennis.
He was about five, four, five, five, and he was a little overweight, you know.
But he's one of my best friends.
He's in California now, but, but, yeah, they were there and then we moved to another house
on, I think it was 17th near the Coliseum.
Okay.
And we never had a problem.
We went over there and the lady, you know, and the rent was 17th.
That was 70 bucks a month.
Wow.
Then there was four of us.
So it was 17th, 50th month.
That's not bad.
You know, plus the oil.
And the oil furnace in there.
But yeah.
And I was nice.
Sure.
I never had any problem finding a place.
Even those only two places.
Well, I lived in an apartment down.
I can't remember the street.
Okay.
But that.
Sure.
Yeah.
I never had any problem with that.
Now, in terms of, you mentioned going to parties, because I remember you said you had met
up Charlie Brown.
I'm sorry.
Charlie White, which is the female in a party.
Did you go to parties that were integrated, or did you go to, when you had a social life,
what was that?
Well, all the time I was here, not one white person that had been invited me to a party that
I would got to recall.
Okay.
Now, I got invited to people's homes to have a drink or some dinner, you know, a thing like that.
But not ever once, a teammate or anyone, never invited me to a party.
But we gave a party every weekend.
Okay.
At your place?
Yes.
A 9th Street.
9th Street of Go-Go is what we called it.
At the time of the Go-Go.
Yeah.
So, all the, obviously, all of the women at our parties were white.
Okay.
Well, with the exception of two or three, because there were Carol Smith and there was three or four
African Americans, women, kind of one of them lived here in Corvallis.
Okay.
And there's a couple of ones from LA and another from, forget about Sacramento or somewhere.
But the majority of the women were white women and also Lloyd Peterson, who's white.
He came to one or two of my parties early on and everybody knew him and nobody, you know,
he didn't have any angst, you know, he's from Los Angeles.
So, he had been around black before and playing ball and black, so he didn't have any problem
with that.
And this Charlie White, I guess he found out we were having a party.
So, he came to one of our parties and introduced us out to us.
He was kidding the guy.
But, you know, we talked a lot of time.
I forgot.
He was from somewhere in Oregon, but, yeah, I met her.
And that was pretty much our parties where, like, we gave parties every weekend.
And we would even host other African-American athletes when they came to town.
If they were staying overnight, we'd say, hey, we're having a party over here, aren't you guys come over?
Yeah.
And they would.
I mean, then everybody has to go either side, don't sit.
Right.
So, they'd come over and, you know, we became friendly with all the athletes in the conference,
up and down the coast, because when they came up here, we went to Washington.
You know, they'd host us, hey, you know, blah, blah, blah.
And then, we had a friend who, from Seattle, who got to school there.
So, when we go up there, you know, she would always have us, you know, over to her place and stuff.
Sure.
And we go to Portland every now and then, so.
Yeah.
What was the relationship like with the police when you guys had these parties?
Was there any kind of...
I don't know.
But I don't know.
The police ever come into our house.
Yeah.
I really don't.
I don't, don't remember.
That's cool.
And what about fraternities?
I mean, that's always been a sore point for a lot of students.
Dealing with fraternities.
I think I got some...
I got to feel from a couple of fraternities who they were.
I don't recall, but I wasn't anything I wanted to do.
Yeah.
On any campus.
Sure.
I'd been in the military.
I knew I lived in barracks and all that stuff with guys.
I had my feeling that I didn't want to do anymore of that.
I was just sitting on.
Yeah.
What I'm getting at though is more of the tension that occurs because fraternity boys always seem to be down on.
In all kinds of negative ways.
Yeah.
You know, things that...
But no.
I think I got like to see a guy feel out by a couple of people maybe invite to something, and I just kind of...
He's not interested in that.
What was I'm interested in?
Okay.
Can you now talk to us a little bit about your going through school then?
So you said your classes really well.
What did you end up as a major in how did you sort of then go on from there?
Well, I majored in business administration with the concentration and personnel and industrial relations.
And I came here and I started here in September I believe of 64.
And I graduated in December of 67.
And so I left here in 68, 67.
Okay.
I got a job with the company called Crown Zellerback, which was the largest one of the largest paper manufacturing firms in the West Coast.
And I got that through one of the alumni.
A guy who had played here with Paul.
Okay.
And he worked for Crown Zellerback.
Now, at that time, affirmative action was big.
Really big.
I mean, yeah.
Any black artist graduate could find a job.
You know, whether you're qualified or not.
And I said to say some were not qualified.
But anyway, I got a job with Crown Zellerback.
And my specific job was to integrate the workforce.
That is company.
Yeah.
And this was in Antioch, California, which was about as a race as you could get.
Really?
Yes.
Antioch is right next to Pittsburgh, California.
Okay.
Now, those two places are all 99.9% of African Americans in that area living in Pittsburgh and all the vice living in Antioch.
I didn't know that.
Well, now I went down there to look for a place to stay.
I'd knock on the door and people would open the door and slam it in my face or some wouldn't open the door.
Right.
So I went into Pittsburgh and I found this apartment house over there, which was not very nice place.
But anyway, I got hard to do that.
And I did a pretty good job.
It was really interesting when I, you know, they wanted African Americans and they wanted more women.
Okay.
Now, this is a manufacturing facility.
Yes.
Now, they had women working already.
Yeah.
But of course, the women could only do certain jobs.
Yes.
Right.
That's very easy.
Well, working in a factory was packing.
Okay.
You know, they couldn't, you know, they couldn't work in shipping.
Got it.
And they had one female lift truck driver, maybe two.
They couldn't operate the machines which paid the most money.
Yeah.
They couldn't do those jobs.
So they were pretty much there, you know, packing the boxes and that sort of thing.
That's the way it was at that time, it's them also.
So, you know, I would hire people.
I would go out in the neighborhood.
I would go out in Pittsburgh where African Americans were Hispanics.
They didn't have a lot of Spanish working there either.
So, I'd go out and I'd get 10 or 12 people to come in.
And at that time, they used to do all this different testing.
The Wonder Lake.
All the time.
Yeah.
You know, and you know, you know, so anyway, we got ready at some point.
But I have 12, 15 people in the room taking this test, you know,
and helping them with it because I'm trying to get people in there.
And I started doing that.
And I'll tell you, the people who were at that facility,
they hated every bit of it.
Yeah.
Now, there were probably 10 or 12 black people working there.
And they had been working there for quite some time.
I mean, they weren't for a few people.
Yeah.
They honestly did out of black person problem in the last 10 years or so.
Right.
But I started filling them up with African Americans, Hispanics, and females.
And they hated it.
They did what they stopped as people there.
They hated it.
I mean, people out to the department, to the supervisor.
And the workers were just stared at me.
I got some bad meal in my inbox, you know, about affirmative action.
And one guy was going to put a George Wallace bumper sticker on my car
and somebody stopped him.
You know what I mean?
It was bad.
Yeah.
I want to come back though, because I forgot one for you.
Part of your story.
You actually got elected as...
I think you got an award here as you called the Leadership Award.
When you got it.
And I think it was 65, 66.
Yeah.
They voted you as...
How did that feel?
I felt great.
Yeah.
Tell me about what happened.
What happened?
Well, it probably made me the captain.
Okay.
What was that like?
I didn't, you know, I surprised me.
Okay.
And I didn't feel any angst from the team.
I wasn't a yellow or a screamer anyway.
Not like...
Well, I was a yellow.
Yeah.
But I would tell guys, you know...
And we would have dialogue.
I wouldn't...
You know...
Even in this stage, you did that.
You know, we would...
I want to do this.
Why don't you do that?
And when they come down here, let's make sure that we do this.
Sure.
Yeah.
That was it.
You know, it wasn't like...
I'm this and you got to do...
Yeah.
It was just like that.
We need to stop these guys.
And this is what we need to do.
Sure.
You know, Paul used to always say,
excuse me in the huddle, he'd say this, this, and this.
And then, as we broke the huddle, he would always say,
what you got to play the situation.
Because it may not come that way, so you got to be waiting for it.
Right.
And that's what I say, too.
Yeah.
They may not go that way.
They may come this way.
They come this way.
We'll do this.
Yeah.
And I feel good about that.
I really do.
Yeah.
He felt good about it, too.
Paul and I had a real special relationship.
Yeah.
That's making the captain.
But more interesting, you reflect on the student leadership award
that you won.
Was there a leadership award?
No, it was a leadership, I think, was just with the team.
With the team?
Yeah.
I thought it was one of the teams.
Okay.
Sure.
Let's come back then to your...
at the company in Antioff.
So was that your job you continued on with?
Or you said that you were...
I did that for a while.
And then I wanted to learn some more about the business.
So I took a production job.
Okay.
And...
Well, let me go back a little bit.
Yeah, I just...
When I was bringing these people in to go to work,
they had what they called a probationary period.
For these people?
For the new employees.
Which were only 30 days, which is not a lot of time.
No.
But they were terminating these people as fast, almost as fast as I can.
After two, two, three weeks, almost 30 days up,
and they just said, well, they can't do the job.
Yeah.
Now, I said, well, wait a minute, something's wrong.
So a Hispanic gentleman named Leo Mijadis.
I don't remember him.
He and I used to talk.
And he came to me and said, you know, they're not giving these guys a chance.
Yeah.
They're not training them right?
So after 30 days, these people can't do the job.
They're kicking them out.
Right.
So we got to do something.
I said, well, he was a union steward also.
So I said, I'll tell you what we're going to do.
We said how we made up a form that had to be filled out every week.
Right.
The supervisor?
What was taught to this just, you know,
and this person, male, female, whatever,
had to agree.
Yes.
So at the end of the week, we would sit out with the union steward, myself,
and the department supervisor, not the guy who trained him a department supervisor,
and go over that.
And that guy said, nobody told me this, nobody told me that.
Right.
Then we could extend this probation period,
and then we made sure that they got the correct training.
Right.
Because we did that on a weekly basis.
Took all the time, but, you know, we did it.
Right.
And we kept starting being able to retain people.
Because hiring people costs money.
It's a lot of working.
And you send them for physicals.
You spend money, and then they kick them out.
Right.
So we did that.
But then I wanted to expand.
And so I went out in production.
Work production for our shift.
Work plus production paid a little more money.
And then I was learning a little more about the business.
And then the safety manager left.
And I decided, you know, I had enough for shift work.
And I decided to go back in the personnel office,
since I've got my pay scale up.
And I went back in as the safety manager.
Now I worked there for eight years.
Okay.
And, you know, doing all this time.
And then I had an opportunity to go with a large construction firm
called Lone Star Industries, which was covered five states,
California, Washington, Oregon, Utah, and Hawaii.
Oh, okay.
So.
So often you get a job.
And then I was regional safety manager,
which was a big job.
And I have, you know, to get your car and all that stuff.
You get to travel a lot.
So I took that job.
Did you have a family, at that point, or you were still?
Yeah, I had one son.
You had something like that.
I had a son in 1970.
Okay.
Sure.
Did you ever have any aspirations to be in coach?
Because I mean, after you leave basketball,
I mean, a lot of guys kind of me have that aspiration saying,
hey, you know what?
I can probably do some of this stuff.
Well, you know, I did a...
I drove close to freshman here a little bit.
Okay.
You know, and right after I stopped playing.
And I guess the reason I didn't stay in coaching,
I wanted to get back to California, really.
And so I thought the quickest way for me to get back was to
pursue my degree.
But otherwise, I thought about it after me.
It's not right after me.
Maybe 10 years after me.
But I was very disappointed when Paul quit.
1970.
Yeah.
He had to head coaching down for six, seven years.
Right.
And he just gave it up.
Paul was pretty disappointed.
Did you ever talk to him about why that was?
Because we didn't.
Well, yeah, I don't know that he'd want to...
Okay.
Well, that's...
You know.
Now, in terms of your connection back to Detroit,
it sounds like that got severed a long time ago.
Oh.
Meaning that you never really went...
How'd the aspiration to go back there?
No, not to do it.
No.
You kept your family back there.
Oh, yeah.
In terms of, yeah.
But what happened is, five or six of my nieces and nephews
came to California.
Oh.
But only one state.
Okay.
They all came.
One went to Los Angeles.
They stayed a while.
They don't have a one state.
He's still in California.
But they all went back to Detroit.
But yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
My family, other than my nephews,
here is...
They're all in Detroit.
Oh, okay.
And so you do make regular...
Yeah.
I do.
Went back last year, twice.
So this year, just recently, when I was in Las Vegas,
my nephews graduated.
So a bunch of them came out.
So we had a nice little family reunion last weekend.
Yes, sure.
So I'm going back in August.
One of my nieces is getting married.
So I'm going to go back for that.
But I'm going to be out of there before winter.
I'm going back last September.
I'm going back last September and stayed two weeks.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Carry on the story a little further than...
You finished working eight years, or so you said,
as in any other thing you said you wanted to do,
the supervisor position where you were first now.
Regional.
What else did you have to ask that?
Well, I worked that for a while.
And then that company got bought up and they downsized
and everything.
So I went to work for a shopping mall.
I was the safety director at a large shopping mall
and then near San Francisco.
And I worked there for quite a few years.
And then I got into contract security.
I ran the contract security firm in Oakland.
I was the branch manager there for 12 years.
And then just before I was thinking about retiring,
I went to work for Bayer.
Bayer, come back.
That's pretty good.
Yes.
And I worked for them in Berkeley for two years
and then I finally retired.
2004.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
But then I got bored.
Okay.
So 2006 rolls around.
I'm at home and I look across the street
and I see these kids playing basketball over there.
It was a school for mentally challenged youth.
So I went over there.
Yeah.
They have basketball.
I see them what they were doing.
And their people were there with nice.
And they talked me into driving the school bus.
Yeah.
Because these guys were pretty hard.
They had a lot of female drivers
and these guys, they were tough holding the women.
So I did that for three and a half years.
And I enjoyed it so much.
And then I try not to escape at all.
Yeah.
Now, coming back to playing ball, though,
or not just playing ball.
And after you left Oregon State,
did you ever sort of just play
or keep working out or any of those kind of things with ball?
Oh, I played it.
Yeah, I played it.
They're not there, you.
But I played for different teams all over the Northern California.
Yeah.
We had quite a network of teams.
Sacramento, you used to have the March of Dimes tournament.
Lake Tahoe had a tournament.
They had a tournament down below Monterey
in a little small town called Gonzales,
which was a bird, but it was a real popular tournament.
A lot of extra college players.
You'd see them all the time.
They'd go down there.
You know, somebody would call me in the middle of the week
and say, hey, we got a game up in Sacramento,
and I'd jump in my car after work.
In Sacramento, an hour and a half away.
And I'd go play.
Yeah, I played a whole lot.
Yeah.
I don't remember when I stopped to land organized,
but I played a lot.
It was hard not to play, I mean.
Yeah, yeah.
It was just something I did, yeah.
And so, you know, wherever I went,
I was, you know, for one of the first things I did,
it was fine, I'm wearing a gas plate ball.
You know, I went over there.
When I went to work down,
and even got out of college,
we had a better company team down there,
across the other back.
And he had, there was a lot of large companies around there,
DuPont, Dow, American, US Steel,
you know, stuff like that.
They all had teams.
And we had a good league,
and we played in that league.
And it was good.
We had a lot of fun doing that.
Now, you were in Annie,
I can, those teams were mostly integrated.
And we never had any incidents that were involved,
but, you know, trying to do something in town initially.
It took a while before they loosened up,
and I got to meet several policemen down there
and I used to hang out at the cop bar, so.
Oh, okay, true.
You know.
Like the round.
Yeah, so everything was cool, you know,
because some of the,
I had hired some of the policemen's kids.
Oh, to be okay.
And to where I worked for the summers, you know,
they worked on it.
Oh, yeah.
Really good jobs.
Yeah.
Yeah, they worked in,
and so, you know, it was pretty good.
Now, looking back on leaving Oregon State,
did you ever, any aspirations going on,
on to play pressure ball?
Well, I did.
I wanted to play, but I didn't get drafted,
and I didn't want to go take a chance
and not make it,
and then I'm not heading to school yet.
Okay.
Now, they had the teams that they have now
all over the world.
Yes.
Europe and wherever else you want.
They got a team.
They have teams everywhere.
Yeah, they sure did.
Got a job somewhere,
because my nephew went down and played in Argentina
for 13 years.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
So, I could have brought,
but that wasn't available to us at the time I came out.
And I probably would have jumped at that.
Right.
If I knew that I could go,
you know, play for a couple of years in Europe
or someplace and make a little money,
and, you know,
could I could come back and finish?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But you really put school to part,
which is a great thing.
Yeah.
Yep.
Is there any questions you want to ask?
At this point,
because I think we're sort of at the end of what I had to ask.
I think that you can pick up from the archive perspective
that you wanted to ask.
Well, you mentioned Harry Gunner.
So, when he came on the team,
it was the 65-66 season.
Did that change the dynamic at all?
Was that nice to have another?
Oh, yeah.
It was nice to have him.
Plus, he helped us a lot.
He needed his, you know, size and strength.
You know, he didn't start,
but he played a lot.
Yeah.
Yeah, he was our sixth man,
and he was the first guy out of the bitch usually.
And, yeah.
Right.
And now, it's really funny.
Harry and I didn't always room together.
See, so, you know,
because sometimes,
Lloyd and I used to room together most of the time.
But you could always find the three of us
in one of our bedrooms,
you know, because we were close.
Yeah, Roy used to hang with us.
Because Lloyd didn't.
Lloyd hated this place.
Oh, he hated every bit of it.
Right.
Coming from Los Angeles,
and he was one of those players that played,
he was a playground player.
Sure.
Because he'd been playing with back kids all his life,
and he was a playground player.
He had more moves.
I'm telling you the cant of worms, as I say.
And he could play.
Right.
But he and Paul, man, they just did.
They never got together for his three years here.
Wow.
Interesting.
And now, he went on to play professional.
Oh, he did.
They played with Chicago over several years,
yeah, and then he found it.
Now, he married a girl from Madras, Oregon.
Oh, did you know that?
Okay.
But he hated Oregon.
And when he came up here and now,
and he hated it,
he and Paul just never,
they never got along.
Never.
Yeah.
I mean, they were glad at each other
in practice and on the bench,
but, you know, it was just...
Yeah.
And it was a hell of a player.
Right.
Yeah.
Now, in the movie glory road,
there was actually eventually some tension
that occurred between the players.
Mm-hmm.
Just about black and white issues about black players getting
based on the black players taking their jobs.
Sure.
Did you ever get any kind of feeling like that?
No.
We were just so few anyway.
Yeah.
Well, first it was just a piece.
No, I never did it.
I never got any feel.
I've never felt that anywhere.
I've never said it to me right there.
Yeah.
Right.
Anything else?
Well, I want to thank you very, very much.
Okay.
It's a great interview.
And it lasted exactly almost 45 minutes.
Yeah.
It's a great stuff.
So, we really appreciate that.
Okay.
I got to go pick up Paulies.
I know he's probably chomping it a bit.
Okay.
Well, I'm pretty sorry about the other one going on.
Yeah.
Okay.
You know.
Yeah.
But, thank you.
Are you going to be seen, Paul?
Yeah.
Can I give you his plaque?
Sure.